[Music]  it's your choice jane  but i'd regret it every single day if i  didn't ask you to stay here so we could  try and figure this out together what if  you don't come back i'm gonna come back  you could also totally die no i totally  die  i don't know why why because the fact of  the matter is i'm uncountable  about that  because i have something worth living  for now something worth fighting for and  that is you  [Music]  have you been standing there this whole  time  yes  it seems like you are  an emotion god after all  come with me  i have something you might need  there's a maniac who seeks to end us all  and putting together the greatest team  ever are you packed  yes  valkyrie this is the best day of my life  an audience  and giant goats look at those they are  wonderful yes they are they also scream  quite a lot  you said this would be a relaxing  holiday  [Music]  i said it was going to be like a  relaxing holiday  [Music]  you